hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about Augmon and dis importance
and maintaining homeostasis in the body
and then spend some time talking about
two different types of osmoregulation
ogner performers and Osmo regulators so
let's start out by talking about osmosis
because in order to understand any of
the rest of the video you have to have
an understanding of what osmosis is so
autumn OSes is when a solvent typically
water so with solvent molecules pass
through a semipermeable membrane going
from a less concentrated to a more
concentrated solution the effect of that
is to kind of equalize the
concentrations of the solutions on
either side of that semipermeable
membrane and as I said typically we talk
about optimism talking about water and
that's going to be true for the rest of
this video now let's talk about what we
mean by osmolarity so osmolarity is
talking about the concentration or
specifically the ratio of solute to
water so how concentrated the solution
is how many solutes there are per amount
of water and now we get into the real
buzzword for this video and that is Osmo
regulation a little regulation is when
an organism regulate its osmolarity
so when an organism regulate it the
osmolarity of its body fluids in order
to maintain homeostasis now we know that
homeostasis refers to the steady-state
condition of the body so keeping the
body at a good physiological
homeostasis that will allow its various
function to continue and allow the
organism to survive so specifically here
we're talking about the fact that our
cells are surrounded by semipermeable
membranes there are types of channel
proteins called aquaporins that allow
water to go from one side of the
membrane to another and so if the
osmolarity the concentration of solutes
to water inside a and organism is
different than that concentration
outside the organism then you can have
water flowing through the process of
osmosis flowing either in or out of the
organism in order to equalize the
concentration of the solute both inside
and outside the organism now there are
two ways that organisms deal with this
situation two ways in which they also
regulate one is that some organisms are
also conformer other organisms are auto
regulators now although regulators are
more common among animals but first
let's talk about oscar performer
although conformers are are organisms
that match their body's osmolarity to
their external environment so another
way of thinking about this is that an
osmotic and formers are animal that
ensured their internal body fluid our
iso osmotic or iess osmotic with the flu
is in their surrounding environment
system examples of auto performers
include most marine invertebrates like
lobsters of starfish and also some
sharks now there are some pros and cons
for being and an osmotic former the pros
is that all no conformers they don't
have to spend very much energy on
although regulations the con is that the
bodies that also conform and are really
subject to a wide range of osmolarity
broad molarity being the different types
of concentrations that they might
experience of solute to water in their
various environment and so they really
have to be able to withstand what can be
some large swings in in osmolarity so
definitely pros and cons to that
approach although regulators are
organisms that you guessed it regulate
so audible regulators regulate their
body's osmolarity to maintain constant
internal condition so regardless of
what's happening in their environment
they are going to expend energy to
regulate their bodies on molarity to
maintain whatever their preferred
constant osmolarity is so let's talk
briefly about the pros and cons here of
course these will be sort of related to
the relates to the pros and cons of
performance but opposite and what I mean
by that is our regulators have to expend
energy to regulate their internal ausma
Larry you know and so that takes energy
to do that which can be detrimental to
an organism as it's having to work too
hard to do that but of course a pro is
that they do maintain this constant
internal condition and so their various
physiological processes are able to take
place in what are the optimal conditions
for that particular organism rather than
having to deal with the various swings
and osmolarity that Osmo conformers
might have to deal with
so certainly pros and cons to each now
since auto regulation is much more
common among animals I want to give some
examples of it apart we're looking at
the difference between freshwater fish
and marine fish now there are certain
fish that can live in freshwater and
live in saltwater and adapt to both but
that's fairly rare for the most part
freshwater fish cannot survive in both
water and saltwater fish cannot survive
in freshwater and that is because of the
different ways in which they've adapted
to Osmo regulate hopeful about
freshwater fish shirt so here we have a
drawing of a freshwater fish now of
course a fish that lives in freshwater
is going to have a higher concentration
of salt and solutes inside its body then
there will be in the freshwater outside
its body now as a result because there
are more false inside and more
concentrated solution inside water is
going to flow from where it's less
concentrated which is in a freshwater to
where it's more concentrated which is
inside the fish so water is going to be
diffusing into the fish now in order for
it to regulate its internal osmolarity
it has to be able to to deal with this
influx of water and it does this with a
few different mechanism its Gill
actually take up salt whatever fault
they can find in the freshwater to prove
help even out this concentration so that
the water doesn't have to move into the
fish as much to do that although these
steps do not drink water we'll talk
later about how saltwater marine fish
Jim drink water for their particular
form of laws and regulations but fresh
waters they should do not they're having
so much water diffusing into them that
they don't drink it through their mouths
at all
they also excrete very dilute urine
so that means urine that is diluted with
a lot of that excess water to get rid of
it
so much more always coming in now so the
opposite point of view marine fish so to
live in saltwater environment that
saltwater that surrounds them is going
to be the more concentrated solution and
inside their body is going to be less
concentrated and so water is going to
want to flow from inside their body
outward and so that water will just
diffuse out of these fish which can be
dehydrating and problematic but they
have ways to deal with that one is that
their gills actually excrete salt and so
by getting rid of that there's extra
salt
it helps them to balance out this water
movement they also are continuously
drinking water through their mouth so
they'll be taking water in whereas
freshwater fish are only using their
mouths to eat solid food marine fish are
going to use their mouthpiece Ellis's
but also to just be continuously
drinking try to replace the water that
they are losing and then also the marine
fish have mechanisms within their
excretory systems that allow them to
excrete very concentrated urine
this means that their urine is
concentrated as much of it can be so
that it has a lot of solute per unit of
water they don't have to lose too much
water to get rid of their waste product
and that also helps them to to retain
water and prevent dehydration so we can
see here to a extreme example from
animals that live in a kinder opposite
environment now briefly let's talk about
humans because he knows are also Osmo
regulators humans use a specific type of
organs that you have heard of called
kinney some human these kidney to filter
out their blood to remove the waste
products from the blood waste products
either that
from something that perhaps is been
adjusted and cannot be used or waste
products from cellular metabolism the
the kidneys filter these things from the
blood and have mechanisms that allow for
the production of pretty concentrated
urine and that also helped us to retain
water and not to lose too much water
through urination which prevents
dehydration and allows us to maintain
our particular desired of molarity
internal conditions despite what our
environment is like so that is it for
today talking about osmoregulation thank
you for watching biology professor